hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
the 20th of me today and you it's tuned
into games but news as if we needed more
reasons to like Witcher 3 depth CD
Projekt RED they've said that they are
not interested in creating platform
exclusive content co-founder and
all-around great guy Martin against key
said that will not deliver exclusive
content to any of the platforms nor will
we artificially delay release of the
game on any of the platforms because
somebody's pings money for that it's
definitely against our values he went on
to say that they're treating all game is
equally and people will see what they're
doing for the witcher 3 in terms of
marketing cooperation at e3 and since
there's nothing we love more than
hearing about DLC begins that haven't
even come out yet far cry 4 is
delivering preemptively on that one to
be fair the Ubisoft has not been an
official announcement but gamestop has
listed a 30-dollar far cry 4 season pass
for xbox 360 xbox one ps3 and ps4 on
their website just in case you're
worried that you misheard that one there
was no mention of any such pass for PC
the product page indicates that the pass
will go on sale in November alongside
the game but there's no indication just
yet of what it will actually include a
far cry 4 DLC pass in the works wouldn't
be that much of a surprise since Ubisoft
have delivered the same sort of thing
for assassins creed 4 black flag in the
past and for next week's watchdogs it
seems that mario kart 8 could serve as a
reprove to get the wii u off the steady
descent to the pile of failed and
forgotten consoles Nintendo UK's Mario
brand manager Roger length that explains
I certainly feel that Mario Kart 8 can
be the catalyst that will broaden we use
two reasons it's very important for us
that we have a successful launch and
continue the promotion throughout the
year and beyond langford went on to
stress the importance of making sure
gamers know what changes are in the new
installment the game is being offered up
in a bundle with the system and wii
remote in North America and Europe in
addition to Nintendo offering a free
extra wii u game with each purchase
Langford's comments echo those of an
intern
our president satoru iwata who said the
fate of a video game system is often
influenced greatly by the introduction
of a single titled who are two cited the
example of the original pokemon game
selling the game boy but can you think
of any other single title that's been a
system seller let me know your thoughts
in that commenting section down below or
you can chat to me directly on my
Twitter where I'm at jeffs McDonald if
you like free stuff gamespot is giving
away a ps4 a limited edition copy of
watch dogs and one year of PlayStation
Plus so if you want to be in with a
chance to get your hands on all that
hedge against but calm /ps for giveaway
and those are all the things that I want
to tell you about that I hope you have
an excellent rest of day and I'll have
even more news for you tomorrow